ciao maryners e benvenuti in uno nuovissimo video
benvenuti in una nuovissima puntata
di indovinalo con le emoji se vi siete persi
le scorse puntate ovviamente vi
spiegherò brevemente di cosa si tratta
queste sono delle carte hanno due facce
fronte e retro davanti c'è un rettangolo
giallo dentro questo rettangolo giallo
ci sono delle emoji dobbiamo quindi
trovare la parola la frase la canzone
l'artista faccio ovviamente riferimento
alle puntate precedenti per risolvere
appunto questo questa sorta di rebus con
le emoji è arrivato il momento di
iniziare una nuova challenge quella
della travel edition travel edition nel
senso che come appunto si può leggere
anche dietro
parliamo di bandiere di paesi di città
di monumenti
ovviamente non si può partecipare a una
challenge da soli e quindi ho bisogno di
qualcuno che giochi insieme a me e quel
qualcuno è per la prima volta su questo
canale non l'avete mai visto
edoardo ciao saluta il pubblico a casa
iniziamo subito ma guarda che
il lupo perde il pelo ma non il vizio
ognuno di noi avrà a disposizione tre
aiuti
il primo è chiedere a un amico un
parente qualsiasi persona tramite chat
whatsapp il secondo è chiedere aiuto ai
nostri follower di instagram
il terzo è cambiare carta cioé non
la riesco a indovinare ho la
possibilità di prenderne un'altra chi
inizia per primo testa o croce e con cosa lo facciamo
io testa pari pari dispari ok quindi se esce
pari sono io se esce dispari
sei tu sappiamo giocare bisogna
fare un pò così bim bum bam sette dispari mio
io credo che questa challenge sarà molto
difficile ma per entrambi sea watch sea view ma
che roba é sea view eh vista mare morto vero oddio é vero che é tutto in inglese
posso guardare
vai che bandiera é no dai ragazzi ma che
bandiera é sembra una tavoletta di cioccolato appunto è
un paese arabo qatar brava
ti giuro ho sparato a casissimo che
fortuna e la portiamo a casa ma ti giuro ho
sparato a caso la vedo già grigia per me
vabe io ho avuto veramente fortuna dai ci puoi
arrivare
è una cosa che trovi a bordo
tipo sacchetti per vomitare esatto come può essere tradotto in inglese vomit bag
devo dire che non sei molto fortunato per
adesso perché ti avvicini ma non la prendi
niente sei destinata a trovare tutte le
bandiere tu vai non è vero cavolo questa
la so israele no argentina no dai
la sapevo la sapevo é argentina come
io lo sapevo perché mi é venuto da dire israele non puoi andare d'istinto devi essere ponderata
giappone japan cioè capito a no tocca a te brasile rain forest
no scusa non sento l'indizio cioè
inutile che fai quella faccia é un luogo
molto famoso la foresta
amazzonica foresta amazzoniche si
tradurrà cioè ha un altro nome in
inglese amazon rain forest e daje
dobbiamo farlo in italiano cioé ma allora
mettiamo questa regola da adesso che
possiamo dirla in italiano
eh allora la prendo io l'ho buttata io ho detto
foresta amazzonica ah questa neanche in italiano la indovini fra
beh la bandiera quella è la bandiera
dell'australia ha sì sì sì sì quella
cosa che c'é a sydney australian opera house
no scusami non ho capito australian opera house no é sydney opera house prima
cosa ma poi come ci sei arrivato
sento puzza di lettura australian opera
come ci sei arrivato dal microfono all'opera house cioé ma è perché é famosa è la cosa
più famosa di sydney
cos'è è facilissima facilissima che
cos'è las vegas
volevo un attimo destabilizzarti
dai facilissimo germania non hai neanche
avuto il tempo di girarla
dal verso giusto
se ti dico di piú la indovini subito
edoardo stai leggendo in trasparenza ti ho
beccato in pieno non lo so non triangle
triangle stiamo parlando di travel e
tu mi dici triangle eh ma questa bandiera non la conosci giusto una bandiera così
che non conosci con un triangolo non
mi hai detto niente di nuovo cosa ti fa venire in mente un cavolo
di triangolo nel mondo il nord in che senso un triangolo che punta a nord è una
costruzione ah un building dubai
dubai building amore le piramidi dubai building tu sei mai stato a dubai piramidi non ce ne sono a dubai te lo
assicuro dai ma che palle canada bellissimo
saremmo stati cosí 3 ore
che palle le bandiere e ti posso dire
che é in asia utilizzo l'aiuto vabbè
questa te la indovinano subito dimmi almeno il continente ti giuro che non lo so
comunque qua proprio geografia edoardo 0 ma non hai capito io sempre rimandato in
geografia zero senegal no ghana è in europa si ok il portogallo solo bandiere comunque
ma veramente mi sono rotto le balle austria no perú
dai cavolo vediamo se mi hanno risposto mia sorella che ignorante sei quindi thailandia no dai non é giusto
come dire ci devo pensare un pó forse dai
tour eiffel dammi un indizio vabbè dai la chiedo perché
anche io scusatemi anch'io ho il mio
anche lei ha il suo aiuto ah lo so jamaica
avevo paura di sbagliare come prima
honey moon a me tutte le bandiere le
cose a lui le parole la tour eiffel dai
questa non puoi non indovinarla la casa bianca time no time times square duty free
sì dai
cioé dai malesia vabbè peró ho un aiuto un aiuto ok
allora i miei follower velocissimi mi hanno
detto sudafrica cioé appena pubblicata
sì però non è giusto io mi ribello a questa
cosa dai ragazzi obiettivamente
facile facile l'isola di pasqua bagaglio
a mano dai ragazzi però romania train
ticket vabbe ha vinto edoardo
facciamo la conta vogliamo contare dai
ragazzi vogliamo forse contare 123 17 15
di poco dai sono stata sfortunata ragazzi
io voglio soltanto dire una cosa il qatar con il qatar io avevo vinto già tutta la partita
perché chi è che la indovinava questa
non so che dire non so che dire perché
speravo di vincere perché il travel è
una cosa che mi interessa amo e cioè c'è
l'estate che si avvicina quindi
percepisco proprio il travel che mi si
avvicina e quindi facciamo un piccolo recap perché nella prima abbiamo pareggiato
nella seconda ha vinto lei perché si parlava di musica e adesso viaggi
ovviamente ho vinto io ovviamente perché dovevo vincere io cosa ha vinto edoardo una scarpa
col tacco con il pelo rosa
quella lí che mi è arrivata da poco ti piace no
pronta per halloween fammi una faccia da coniglietta vabbè salutiamo i nostri maryners grazie per
averci seguito ci vediamo alla prossima
puntata di indovinalo con le emoji
adoro ciao